we're talking about this young lady a
lot over the last few days the russian
figure skater camila valeeva she's just
15 years old she failed a drugs test on
christmas day she's still going to be
allowed to compete
in the winter olympics
why don't know somebody who may well
know and can cast some light on it for
us is tom in beijing hi tom how can she
compete if she had a positive drugs test
okay yeah this is a legal minefield the
whole thing's really a mess uh the ioc
the international olympic committee have
said that if valeeva's in the top three
there won't be a medal award ceremony
that's the level of controversy and
uncertainty around all of this um the ic
had sought to prevent her competing
following this positive test uh but the
court of arbitration for sports said she
should be allowed to compete and they
looked at a couple things first of all
the fact that this positive result only
came through on february the eighth uh
which wasn't valeeva's fault second the
fact she's a protected person she's less
than 16 years old and that brings in to
play a whole different category they
weren't looking at the positive result
it said just about the decision to let
her compete and their thinking was that
well if down the line they have that
investigation and she's in the clear or
she only gets a very small reprimand
because uh she's found not to be
responsible given that she's only 15
years old she wouldn't be allowed to
compete in the ice skating would be
unfair on her so she will be out there
on the ice i think it'll be hugely
controversial but after um an
extraordinary week she'll be there under
the bright lights for beijing 2022.
okay thank you